[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to stanford it's great to
be here and it's nice to be back
physically with people in the room so
it's terrific yeah and as you can tell
my classmates and i are so excited that
you're here with us today
and this conversation is extra special
for me because your story hits so close
to home
like you my dad is from south india he
is an alumnus of iit and immigrated here
about 30 years ago with grit and
determination he's right here in the
audience
he's a role model for me and so are you
so truly thank you for being here oh the
real pleasure is mine it's very
nostalgic i was just telling john
i saw a volleyball court outside
stanford was the end of my fledgling
volleyball career coming here and seeing
how good people were but it's really
nice to be back
lots of talent around here and you know
when you first became the ceo of google
it created quite a buzz your wikipedia
page had over 350 edits just in the week
that you became the leader
did you have you seen some of these
edits
advice i would have for all of you is
don't read about yourself online
well we thought it'd be a good way to
start the conversation by visiting some
of these wikipedia edits some of our
favorite ones
with fact versus fake news your
wikipedia page edition
first of all someone claimed
that you decided to join iit at the
young age of eight years old fact or
fake
uh i think that was fake i was my
parents were tired of me they sent me to
school i think when i was about two and
a half to kindergarten i was pretty
young when i came to stanford but that
is not true
at the same time everyone wanted to
claim you from their hometown in high
school so there are quite a few edits to
your page on which high school you came
from
where did you go
there are two schools which are right
but the the final school is
which is inside
the campus where your dad went to
college so that's where i went to school
wow okay
so
the person that said you were
homeschooled was definitely wrong
i don't think i was
home schooled unless
it didn't while playing cricket you know
i was in home school
well on that note
were you the captain of your high school
cricket team
i would have loved to be
[Applause]
but i was quite far from it yeah
in another life in your life
so now that we have the metabolism
you're speaking my language
so now that we have the fiction out of
the way we can turn to some of the facts
you grew up in india with limited access
to technology and when you discover
technologies it had a profound impact on
you how did you go from an initial
delight in technology to devoting your
career to access to technology for all
now it was uh you know i had uh
you know growing up for me uh you know
every every technology transition was
very vivid
even as a kid because i had to wait a
long long time for it
uh you know we were on a waitlist for a
rotary telephone it took five years to
be on the waitlist and get the phone
uh you know i would go to get my
grandparents blood test results and it
would be an hour round trip each way and
you would go all the way to the hospital
and they would say it's not ready today
come back
tomorrow and then this phone came and i
could call
and they would tell me whether the
results were ready or not and so to me
that was like super profound and people
would come to our house to make calls i
saw you know how it created a sense of
community so i've always had this
vivid sense of how technology can make a
profound difference and
and so a lot of what i've tried to do is
bring that access to technology what i
got i got a lot more of it when i came
to stanford walking to sweet all at the
time and seeing rows of computers was
life-changing for me
and you know i was very inspired by
negra ponte's one laptop per child uh
project
and and even today a lot of what i'm
able to do at google be it make cheaper
phones through android or bring the next
billion people online or chromebooks
and and try to give make affordable
laptops all hit close to that mission so
definitely yeah and i can tell the way
that you speak about technology it had
this impact on you and it manifested in
your studies as well you got your
engineering degree from iit
and then a master's here at stanford in
engineering and were about to pursue a
career in academia and get your phd
clearly that's not the path you ended up
taking what changed your mind why did
you decide to leave academia at the time
i still once in a while have a
conversation with my dad i think i
disappointed him a little bit not
not getting that phd but
you know i i literally came to silicon
valley for me it was asked literal i
mean this was the place where
semiconductors were built i came here
for the silicon in silicon valley and
you know
i i did my uh i was a phd student in
material science my i was studying
semiconductor physics and and definitely
that's what i thought i would do
a few things one is i was surrounded by
other grad students who had worked on at
the time what was the rage uh it was
superconductors what was called high tc
superconductors and i realized many of
them had spent their life and it didn't
happen and so that that gave me pause uh
you know and i think something you all
probably
deal with being in the valley there's so
much happening outside there's a lot
that beckons outside and so you know was
definitely interested in that
i had financial reasons to go get a job
and so the combination of all that made
me
go out and be in industry and in a great
learning moment the semiconductor
industry is
extraordinarily cyclical in my first
year
and in the company i worked we hired
3000 people and the next year we laid
off 1700 people and so you know you get
out and you go through that life
learning
but that was the early days of the
internet too and definitely seeing what
the promise the internet had
and and connecting it back to what i
wanted to do uh you know was what uh let
me
find my way back to google and i went to
business school along the way not here
but another great school and and
eventually made it back to the valley
yeah it seems like you saw the rapid
change of technology outside of academia
oh yeah you know you know you both
stanford itself is a special place i
think there are
uh you know most faculty here are very
uh you know it's it's a very symbiotic
relationship which i've always thought
is unique amongst uh
many places in the world and and so
definitely both being in the campus you
get a good sense for what's happening
outside and and going to industry here
you know you really get the
sense for the dynamism we take it for
granted but you know as i travel around
the world most people outside are trying
to understand how the valley works and
how to how to do better so you know it's
an extraordinary place
yeah and and many of us here are in a
transitory period of our lives figuring
out which industry we want to go and
impact uh you've been at google for now
quite a while 20 years
uh and faced several crossroads during
your time
sometimes choosing to leave an industry
is as difficult as choosing to stay
what drew you to stay at google over the
past 20
years it's been very busy partly that
and uh
you know i
it's an extraordinary place uh you know
i think uh the breadth of talent you see
uh uh you know the kind of
projects you you you get exposed to
uh you know you're on the cutting edge
of everything uh it's like i'm not a
surfer but i use this energy i don't
know why but it's like i've tried a
couple times and i failed but it feels
like you know surfing and being on the
edge of something all the time
so definitely i enjoy that and a big
part of it is uh you know if you look at
our products you know search works
everywhere around the world you know we
take pride in providing it and it's
accessible to everyone as long as they
have computing and connectivity
whether you're
here at stanford or
kid in rural indonesia
google works for you and and that's the
philosophy we bring across our products
uh we gmail will be maps we eat youtube
so we think about scale being able to
reach
uh people and and make technology more
accessible and and it's what i wanted to
do in my life and so it's a privilege to
do it
yeah and there's no shortage of products
to work on now there's no shortage
sometimes too many at google but that's
another story yeah one of the early
products that you worked on was chrome
you led the team and initially there was
some pushback
high development costs competitors in
the space
but you had conviction that the browser
was the way to go
where did the conviction come from and
how did you convince skeptics that
chrome was the future
at the time eric was our ceo eric
schmidt and you know
i remember him being angry once and say
because he realized we were trying to
build a browser and he was like do you
know what it takes to build a browser
you know it takes
because he had gone through the browser
battles
he definitely didn't you know was
hesitant for us to do it
uh partly how did i do it i didn't tell
people uh for a while
just had a small team and you know
worked on it and uh
and only when we had something to show
uh you know uh you know we had a chance
to
show the product and that got people
excited and so
but it is uh you know it's a good lesson
i think if you have a set of committed
people uh passionate people you can you
can achieve you know even i couldn't
have foreseen what it would eventually
become but you know shows the power of a
small group of committed people
and and actually not knowing the odds of
what you're working on so i think both
helps
yeah and you can obviously see the
direction that chrome grew into as one
of the most popular browsers today
and you really have seen
google transition from pre-ipo to the
trillion dollar company it is today
challenging it's challenging to scale an
organization of that size
over the years what do you think google
has done well as it scaled
you know i mean
there
it is it is a complex thing scaling a
company i would say things we have
gotten right
the first thing that struck me about
google when i joined the company it was
very different in the sense that it was
a very optimistic place so it was a rare
place in which if you walked the
hallways and you spoke to people and you
had ideas people expanded on them you
know
most of the times people try to tell you
why things won't work
i felt the spirit was different you know
people would tell you oh that's a great
idea you could do it this way and it
would be better
so that struck me that optimism uh the
fact that you can innovate make things
better solve problems
uh i think i think is is a spirit i've
tried to carry
now and it takes a lot of hard work
uh you have to encourage innovation
you know one of the counterintuitive
things is companies become more
conservative
as they grow
you have a lot more cash you have a lot
more resources but you know companies
tend to become more conservative in
their decision making
and so encouraging the company to take
risks and innovate and be okay with
failure and
and reward effort not outcomes
and that's very hard to do in an
organization people tend to reward
outcomes
and which means over time the
organization becomes more conservative
they take safer bets
and and so on so a lot of scaling up is
about making sure you preserve
the good things you had in the early
days and that gets harder as the company
becomes bigger you have to work harder
at it but i think a big part of what we
try hard to do is keep that
culture of uh innovating with technology
building products
shipping things and you know and so that
that's one of the many things but yeah
yeah and maintaining that culture as the
company grows is not easy
it's a difficult endeavor what were some
of the other kind of growing pains that
you've seen google have over the last
couple of years
you know i mean uh
definitely a lot i mean when you're a
small company you know think about the
size of the business school all of you
have
shared context you know you understand
better what others are going through and
so you have
better
context around everything that's going
on a larger company definitely gets
harder right and google was built on
you know everyone it's a very open
culture even today one of the most
common things people tell me when they
come from other companies is
you know they're shocked at how
transparent the company is you know you
have literally access to what's
happening across the company
but it can be overwhelming and just
because you have transparency doesn't
mean you have context
uh it's very different from
when when organizations are smaller
so that's been a big part of trying to
figure out how to scale up the company
and how do you
how do you organize more independently
coordinate only when needed
but can have more parts of the company
move as smaller units
and that's a hard balance to get right
yeah and and now you're at the helm of
google and you see all these teams
working in different directions but one
thing that you've been vocal about and
enthusiastic about is ai
you've said
ai is the most important thing humanity
has ever worked on and many of us will
go on to work with ai or advanced
computing in some form how should we be
thinking about ai to help help humanity
versus harm humanity
that's a great question uh you know when
i became ceo one of the biggest uh uh
directional changes we made is we said
you know we're gonna approach everything
as ai first and uh we are applying it
across everything we do in the company
it's a big part of the r d v span
and and the progress is uh you know
palpable every year uh you know uh it's
exciting there's a lot of progress
um you know i think uh you know we
concretely see the evidence of uh
just when you look at the scale at which
translation works uh
you know
or in search how we use ai or in gmail
when you type and we give suggestions
you know it's applied across all our
products and so and it definitely you
know we can see the path by which we're
making things better
i think it'll profoundly transform
pretty much every sector
uh you know
you see the potential in areas like
healthcare i think it'll still take a
decade for it to fully play out
uh but we definitely see the potential
i think to your question of uh how do
you make sure uh you know
we develop it in a way i think that the
essential struggle of humanity with
every technology
is you know harnessing it so that it
benefits society
uh you know you can see the same debates
about the internet uh even before you
think about ai you know has the internet
been a force of good
obviously uh you know has it had had
effects which we didn't fully anticipate
yes and we are you know and that's
that's the debate and we are working
about how best to address it with ai i
think we need to think about it earlier
so you know part of how we are
approaching you know we have clearly
articulated publicly a set of ai
principles
and and publicly stated it but and we
publish a lot of research we open source
technology
but that's only part of the problem i
think academic institutions need to play
a big role we were a founding member for
stanford's uh ai institute hai and
and and proud to be a supporter there uh
i think they're doing terrific work but
in academic institutions non-profits
and the public private partnership
government will end up having a role uh
there has to be regulation thoughtful
regulation about ai you have to get the
balance right so that there is
innovation but you know i think it's
important to think it through
earlier than other technologies so i
think
uh and and and so doing it and engaging
all the stakeholders is the only way i
can think of
uh think of approaching it
so it seems like it's a living breathing
framework that evolves as ai also
evolves that's right and it needs to
involve uh you know many people from our
you know from many different
institutions to make it work
yeah i want to touch on your point on
technology
being being forward about technology and
thinking about the benefits and harms as
we're building it
in a post-covered world many of us have
realized the importance of human
connection and we crave human connection
yet sometimes technology can breed
disconnection
how are you thinking about the future of
quality connections with each other
as technology becomes a larger part of
our lives
i mean
technology is an enabler ultimately you
know it's people in society you know we
have to organize around how we how we
use technology
i think uh you know you're raising a
very important point and uh uh
you know thinking through about how
technology is not isolating uh or or
you know immersive in a way in which it
prevents you from engaging i think
genuinely is a good topic i think all of
us
who have uh you know kids uh you know
worry about it and struggle about it i
did like when our sons were playing in
the middle school band uh you know it's
what you want to see them do more of
but uh you know
every generation always is very worried
about technology of the future it's
always been true when you look back look
back at it and and and so i think you
know that's part of the process
uh technology done correctly uh can
enable interactions in the real world
you know one of the companies we spun
out of google which was niantic
did that precisely that with pokemon and
got people to move about and do stuff in
the real world which i found inspiring
but
i think uh you know i think over time
uh part of even if we get augmented
reality right
today you know when you see people on
their phones walking on the streets
immersed you know you see that in some
ways technology forces you
to engage with it it hasn't adapted
enough to how humans live life
and so part of solving
you know more natural ways by which you
can interact with computing be it voice
be computing understanding what you're
looking at
you know may actually help us do this
better
done
wrongly can be even more isolating but
done correctly with the right attributes
i think i think it can help bridge that
gap and so i think that's a potential
for ar if done correctly
yeah so it's thinking in advance about
the implications and then being there as
the technology develops that's right
yeah
i want to take a step back and look at
google more as a whole
some of the biases we've talked about
with ai but more with more broadly what
goes on with google's culture in 2018
employees staged a walkout for women's
rights
in 2020 google was accused of
mishandling the treatment of minorities
on the ethical ai team
to start us off as these events were
happening what was going through your
head what was your reaction
you know one of the fortunate things i
felt is uh
you know unlike most companies from day
one google has had a strong employee
voice
and
for me as a ceo running a large company
uh you know always found it helpful
because you know you trust your
employees to get it right at scale
so you know i view it as a strength of
the company when employees speak up i
think it's important for us to take it
seriously
the walkout was a moment when the
company hadn't gotten something right
and that's what
the walkout was about so internalizing
it acknowledging it owning up to it and
making the com committing and making the
company better
is you know how you approach those
moments
and even today i think employee input is
something as a company we value deeply
and i would argue
they pushed the company to be better
across all the things we do
you know it is complex as i said earlier
uh the context around these decisions
some of these decisions are always hard
uh and at scale not everyone has the
full context
but for what it's worth i've personally
always felt one of the strengths of the
company
and when it comes to be being getting ai
right or doing things at scale and
getting it right
you know and we do it in many countries
around the world and you know i still
today take great comfort in knowing that
our employees
you know
deeply our guardian of guardians of our
values and we'll do everything to get it
right
yeah and
i guess these past
events help inform the future decision
making of google
uh how are you thinking about promoting
de ni diversity equity and inclusion at
google moving forward
you know one of the most important
moments as a company we went through and
i think many companies around the world
uh was
the racial equity moment around the
murder of george floyd you know as a
company for us
uh it was a profound moment internally
i've never seen anything affect the
company that much uh in in the 16 years
we publicly committed to you know i
consulted and worked with our black
leadership advisory group in the company
and you know understanding most of the
company
wanted to do the right thing tapping on
the moment and converting it into
lasting commitment
so we have publicly committed to a set
of initiatives and we are holding
ourselves accountable we give
transparency reports on how we are
making progress on that
and and be it uh you know committing to
improving our uh leadership
representation uh
from underrepresented groups
uh be committing to driving improvements
in our products uh you know last year in
pixel and in our camera technology we
launched real tone uh you know a more
inclusive way to capture pictures
uh to cover all skin tones i mean these
are all examples of how you can use
technology to
make progress here uh skilling uh and
and giving more people access to
technology particularly in
underrepresented groups these are all
commitments we have made and you know
and and you know that's once one part of
how we
work through moments like those yeah so
it seems like you're taking a
technological approach as well as an
empathetic approach listening to your
employees hearing what they have to say
what's top of mind for employees right
now is the future of work
you recently released your future of
work plan for google employees
and
i can imagine you're balancing a lot of
perspectives that are competing how did
you integrate competing preferences when
crafting your future of plan work
you know for me for its work i am
incredibly excited about this next phase
of the future of work and uh
i think 20 years ago google was kind of
it's now done so much around the valley
people take it for granted but google
did rethink what workspaces could be you
know they thought workspaces could be
fun we had slides in our offices you
know we bridged
uh
you know we changed workplaces pretty
radically we gave people a lot of agency
our employees had a lot of agency
it felt fun to be in the offices
and we didn't think that was at odds of
being productive right so the sense of
creating
community
uh fostering creativity in the workplace
collaboration all makes you a better
company
i view giving flexibility to people the
same way
to be very clear i do think
we strongly believe in in-person
connections
but i think we can achieve that in a
more purposeful way
and give employees again more agency and
flexibility
so i think hybrid work is great we're
going to leverage the scale of the
company we have many locations around
the world so people can move to other
places and work
we are starting with a 3-2 hybrid option
but we have encouraged employees to
apply to be fully remote as well and
you know we have supported 85 of those
applications
so i'm excited you know you earlier
asked about
uh you know diversity one of the best
ways we can now approach diversity is
actually showing up in places where
diverse talent is
more importantly when we get that talent
them being in communities which have the
supporting
structure for them
and so we are now in atlanta in chicago
in dc uh you know recruiting employees
uh i think being able to
support the participation of women in
the workforce i think the flexibility is
going to be a huge asset
so i'm excited by it and i think uh you
know and i think i find when people come
back and people are very excited to come
back to the office by the way uh you
know as we have opened up we are easily
at over 70 percent already back to our
pre-pandemic
uh you know presence in the offices and
it's growing
but giving people that choice it always
bothered me that uh the stress around
commutes
or when people at parent-teacher
conferences and or doctor appointments
balancing all that you know there's a
lot of stress which people are carrying
so i think it gets gives us a chance to
rethink
also as a technology since we build uh
products like gmail docs meat and so on
it gives a chance to rethink products
too and and and make it all work better
so
uh you know you know i i think it's one
of the most exciting
things that's happening in uh in the
workforce uh you know and i i think
you'll see the benefits of it over time
yeah absolutely it seems like you're
emphasizing intentionality and
flexibility when it comes to hybrid work
and your plans really do set the stage
for other companies in silicon valley
and beyond
so we're all looking to you and your
leadership for for guidance on things
like this
uh so you also recently just got back
from warsaw
you were helping out with the ukraine
refugee crisis
uh how do you
when is it appropriate for corporations
to step in on public issues
like ukraine russia
well first of all uh you know for us we
are directly
involved because both we have employees
in ukraine and russia
uh our products work in these regions
being an information company at moments
like this uh you know it you know it's
really critical for us to get these
moments right
so we approach it a few ways foremost
the safety of our employees like every
other organization making sure employees
are safe
uh second very critical for us is
getting access to information right
tackling misinformation
removing
uh
you know what we felt were
propaganda information
and raising what we do in search in
youtube but moments like that is raising
higher quality information
including providing information within
russia at moments like this
uh you know it's been a large part of
the work we do
launching important things like air raid
alerts on google maps and ukraine
uh being in warsaw uh one of the things
that struck me uh and it's true for
pretty much everyone there
an average google employee had
two to three refugee families with them
these are mainly women and children
uh you know people don't speak the same
language all the time people using
google translate on their phones to
communicate so we had to do a sprint to
get the language translation working
right we opened up portion of our space
to ngos
as well as uh entrepreneurs from ukraine
and more importantly we committed to
investing in poland so we
announced a 700 million dollar
investment
both in office space and to hire more
people in poland and we're going to come
into investing in central and eastern
europe at this at this pivotal time
but i think uh it definitely the the war
shows how much uh you know we have to
continue fighting for and so it's an
important moment to get right yeah it's
uh it's incredible to see corporations
like google committing time resources
financial investment and technology to
causes like this and i'm personally in
awe of how many causes that you're
invested in
apart from ukraine russia you also have
announced plans recently in investment
in africa and things like job skills
training for low to middle income folks
more broadly how do you choose which
causes you want to invest your time and
effort into
it's a great question uh you know with
the company at scale there are there's a
lot of things that come your way i i
think you have to be disciplined about
where you think google can make a
difference and you know what is a
unique perspective or value proposition
you can bring to the table and and you
know over time we have understood by
things we can do well and things
other organizations are better at doing
uh an area for example given our focus
on information uh skilling has been a
big focus for us uh digital skilling i
think you know there is no substitute
for college but unfortunately not
everyone can you know has access to
access to and can afford to go to a
college and so
skilling people bringing them
giving them access to digital skills has
been a big push
in the u.s we launched a career
certificate program it's a nine-month
program we've done it on four major
areas
and and and we back it up with working
with employers to recruit people
and it's been extraordinarily successful
75 000 people have gone through it and
and you know almost 50 percent of it is
from underrepresented groups and when i
look at the demand there is from people
for these things and so i think as a
society we need to figure out about how
we can scale and and give access to
digital skilling to more people so but
that's an area where we feel google can
strongly contribute and and uh so we we
choose and get involved in areas like
that sustainability is another one so
you know we
choose where we think we can add value
yeah so it seems like you look at your
strengths and then look at what impact
you can make based off of your strengths
and pursue those issues that's right
yeah and you touched on this briefly but
sustainability
a couple years ago you announced this
lofty goal of being carbon neutral at
google by 2030
and you have to unify many business
units and product lines to achieve this
goal how are you going about getting the
whole company to rally behind a goal of
sustainability
look one of the important things and if
i could clarify one thing because it's
settling people we've been carbon
neutral since 2007.
so google has been carbon neutral since
2007 and one of the earliest companies
to do so sustainability has long been an
important goal
what we have now committed
is
by 2030 to be carbon free so not using
offsets uh and but actually running our
operations 24 7 uh carbon free that is a
hard challenge
um
because today we can use offsets and you
know and that involves
investing and developing new
technologies beyond wind and solar
uh
you know be carbon
carbon capture how do you store energy
and to do it around the world
and so but it excites us because it's a
lot of r d again
and you can apply technology
and when we
we bought some of the earliest wind and
solar contracts in 2010 and costs have
fallen by 85 percent in the last 10
years and so again looking at these new
technologies we just have a whole data
center now up and running with
geothermal
and so tapping into new technologies and
we want to
bootstrap it and and help drive the
technology and the cost curve uh over
the next decade uh so that we can reach
there but it's a challenge it stresses
us out
uh but i you know incredibly excited as
a technologist the chance to make
progress like that yeah and you know
none of these big initiatives were asked
of you and asked of google these are
things that you as a company and you as
a leader have decided to take on
the the theme for our slate of speakers
this year is beyond expectations
so we'd love to hear what motivates you
to go above and beyond what is expected
of a business leader
you know
i would tie it back to the first
question at least in the context of the
work i do
you know i travel around the world and
you know i still today particularly when
you go into emerging markets
it's a very different view from here you
see
how
eager people are to get access to
technology because they understand uh
how it will make their lives better so
you see it you feel it and i go to
vietnam or india or africa
and and so
you know and there's a lot more work to
be done and
and just in india recently uh we are
working on you know a cheaper high
quality smartphone maybe around the 30
price point
uh and last week we just announced in
africa
our product development center in
nairobi hiring engineers ux designers
and so on
when you see the appetite and the desire
for people to make their lives better by
gaining access to technology you know
that's what couples me to go beyond and
and it's i i think it's very consistent
with what our company is set out to do
yeah i can tell how much intentionality
you have behind
all the initiatives within google and
externally so truly thank you so much
for giving us a framework and ideas
behind how you make decisions that we
can kind of take away from here
with that we do have student questions
so we can turn it over
right there
hi sundar my name is melissa jang and i
was a former tapestry employee so great
to meet you
my question is going back to the year or
forward to the year 2030
in what capacity do you see alphabet
partnering the most with governments and
this can be from tech access to grids
to
search
and what will make you feel most proud
of getting right
you know second part is uh you know i do
think
sustainability is going to be the
defining issue uh for uh for us to get
right in the next decade or so
so we are definitely you know committing
alphabet uh seriously just just to get
to a carbon free goal
would it would
involve billions of dollars in
incremental investment from us uh but we
think it's the right thing to do it'll
be good for us as a business i think
over time
but but i think uh you know that is
something i want us to be able to get
right and i think i definitely something
we'd be proud of if you can get there
first question i presume you're asking
by 2030 how do you see us engaging with
governments and so on look i think tech
tech one of the bigger you know more
profound changes underway is i think
technology is going to be a regulated
industry and
and
part of you know as a company working at
scale is anticipating working
constructively with regulators and and
and
because i think at the end of the day
technology affects citizens and so every
country is going to be thinking about
this deeply
and take europe's gdpr as an example
it's an important foundational privacy
legislation
right and i think we we had to
anticipate it we invested almost 18
months of work to get ready for it
and and i think it's given certainty to
both european citizens
it gives businesses certainty about how
to operate so that's one example of
legislation working
and and so you know we would expect to
be constructively working with uh you
know governments around the world uh you
know arsenal mentioned ai and you know i
think that's going to be important for
us to get right and and i think
governments will end up playing a key
role in the time frame
hi cinder i'm shanice thank you for
being here
yesterday we had the privilege of having
barack obama on campus and he spoke
about how changes in the way we
communicate and consume information
has a massive impact on our democracy so
while google is not a social media
company i'm curious to know what you see
google's role in that debate is
i mean first of all i think it was an
important speech and uh
you know i think this is something we
think about deeply it's it's in our
stated mission uh you know if you think
about search
this is what we are trying to do for
every query right we are trying to
sort what is higher quality information
and so it's
it cuts to the essence of uh what we do
you know in youtube we brought the same
principles
one exam such a complex topic but maybe
i can answer it with an example
uh
you know it's it's actually easier to do
this as a company when society agrees
on an area so when there is when society
converges and agree you can see that
happening in the context of the war
russia ukraine and i think that's why
you see
a lot of companies able to be able to
get it right when society is very
divided
about where to draw the lines uh you
know it inherently gets harder
but the way we approach is generally uh
you know uh on on important areas to use
youtube as an example we raise what we
think of as authoritative information
that's journalistic content
or or in the case of
if it's health related uh you know maybe
from universities or academic
hospitals
or uh you know public health
organizations
so we
we use those tools just like we have
done search
to try and think hard about what are
higher quality sources of information
and we view that as a goal and you know
that's one way by which we tackle the
problem
but it's an important issue and i think
part of it is
you know
if there are better rules including laws
and legislation i think it will actually
make it easier but you'll find writing
the law and legislation is hard
because i think as a society we're still
grappling with what
what we think is the right answer for
many many of these things
hi sundar i'm the other archana at the
business school
and also from madras so it's really nice
to meet you i used to work for the gates
foundation thinking about bringing
innovation to
emerging markets and underserved people
so everything you say resonates my
question is a more personal one doing
the work you do there are many difficult
days difficult moments highs and lows do
you have any everyday habits or personal
mantras that keep you going when things
get tough
it's a great question uh first of all i
mean most decisions
it took me a while to realize when
decisions come to you
you know the higher up you're in an
organization
the easy decisions don't come to you
right and
by definition when something has come to
you
it's because you know others have spent
time on it and they can't resolve it
so in some ways i i realize that so two
things one is i think you making that
decision
is the most important thing you can do
you you know we you know you're breaking
a tie and it unlocks the organization to
move forward
and uh and so you know and it's it's an
important thing one of the mentors here
bill campbell uh you know thought that
to me early every week you would see me
you would ask me what ties did you break
this week
and and so it's always struck with me so
i view making these decisions as you
know you're really helping the company
and so that that makes it a bit more fun
the second is you know with time you
realize most of those decisions are
inconsequential
it might appear very tough at the time
you know it may feel like a lot rides on
it but he looked later and he realized
you know it wasn't that consequential
there are a few consequential uh
decisions and judgment is a big part of
leadership and you don't always get it
right and you have to learn from it
but i think
most decisions aren't that consequential
and so you know so thinking through both
helps me think about it as it's just
another normal day in the office and so
you keep going through it
all right so i think we have time for
one more question right back there
hi sundar my name is nick boshore
i'm from syria and in syria 20 million
people
don't have access to all of the products
that google produces
that's because of regulations that are
put in place by countries like the
united states and certain countries the
european union european union so on top
of being under a dictatorship 20 million
syrians don't have access to the
financial world don't have access to
basic technology products
and
the gap between the developed and
developing world is really just
increasing
you're one of the most important leaders
in the world
what are you doing to advocate on behalf
of these people
and to give truly universal access to
technology products
thank you
that's a great question uh you know as a
company you know our mission is to
provide universal access to information
and you know any time
uh you know we are not able to do that
for a set of reasons i mean you know we
struggle with it you know we feel
compelled to try to find a way
we do have to comply with laws as a
company and you know and
in in areas like syria uh the way the
ways we have contributed uh a you know
we are we've been involved in the
refugee work round uh you know syrian
refugees for a long time
you know we build access to open source
technologies uh in many of these cases
and you know and and
support things android is open source
things do make their way uh in into
these countries so we work at an open
source level in areas where we are not
fully able to directly work
but i think you know it's an important
question i don't have all the answers
here but thanks for asking it and you
know i'll think about it more
awesome so we typically conclude our
conversations with a lightning round
i will start a sentence and you will
finish it so it's a fill in the blank
so first of all something that inspires
me is
you know
watching the next generation blossom and
you know i think uh
society always worries that the next
generation isn't as good as they are
that is not true
and the next generation ends up making
the world even better so that inspires
me
i am the most proud of
trying my best to do the right thing by
the people i i'm involved with both
obviously personally and and
professionally people i work with
during my time at stanford i loved
i you know i used to love uh
just being out in the court and sitting
and grabbing lunch with friends driving
today reminded me of that for sure
i am the happiest when
uh many things but you know being around
uh people building products and solving
problems uh you know still something
makes me very happy and finally the best
piece of leadership advice i've received
is
you know be authentic to yourself and
and be the best leader you can be i
think there's no one right template and
don't try to be
in someone else's mold
it's wonderful sunder thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
you